[Musique]
la brasserie o'clock existe depuis 2015
donc c'est une brasserie qui a été
fondée par trois amis d'enfance donc
quand un kevin et moi même donc nous on
se connaît depuis qu'on est au collège
et on a brassé notre première bière
quand on était au lycée et à la fin nos
études on a décidé de vraiment de se
lancer dans la brasserie et de créer
notre propre marque qui est donc la
bière o'clock la brasserie au club
brewing et donc on est installé depuis
2015 à à bois d'arcy pour fabriquer une
bière on va utiliser principalement de
l'eau du malt
du houblon et de la levure une fois
qu'on a assemblé tout ça et qu'on a
mélangé tout ça on lance une
fermentation et on a eu une bière qui
finit par être une bière en bouteille un
petit peu comme cette comme cette jet
lag qui à nos produits phares qui est la
bière aujourd'hui qu'on vend le plus
c'est notre amitié c'est une bière créer
à la fois très aromatique qui développe
pas mal d'amertume l'idée c'est vraiment
de proposer un produit différent de ce
que on connaissait habituellement en
tout cas différent de ce que faisait les
biens et les brasseurs industriels
ensuite on a voulu développer chez au
clac une gamme de produits un peu
atypique qui est la gamme palène power
l'idée c'est de faire vieillir les
bières dans des barriques et ses
barriques ont une histoire et c'est de
profiter de l'histoire de cette barrique
pour créer un espèce d'effet surprise
sur nos produits sur le produit fini
donc en fait on achète des barriques qui
ont compté du cognac du bourbon de la
tequila du rhum et l'idée c'est vraiment
de profiter de ce 2e set de cette
histoire pour apporter une vraie valeur
ajoutée à d'autres produits et en créer
un produit très atypique et original